you know certainly yeah i've at times
i've felt like a setting second-class
citizen in uh in japan because
you know before i would never have
accused japan of uh you know that that
level of uh discrimination but yeah
covert has really kind of brought a
weird side of japan that's a bit
uncomfortable a lot of people are
supposed to sort of
tainted their long-term future here yeah
a really good article about how like all
these travel restrictions have really
like tainted how a lot of people view
japan unfortunately they've just kind of
just completely [ __ ] over foreigners
who had jobs residents here like really
[ __ ] students absolutely [ __ ] over a
ton of people
and now they just put them back and said
they're gonna keep them going again
right after they release them it's
really [ __ ] it is bad yeah well i
remember like you got so bad that the
american embassy even made a tweet right
didn't it yeah yeah yeah yeah
jesus was the tweet it was sent like
we've been informed that japanese police
are randomly stopping foreigners and
searching them oh yeah i had that the
other day yeah yeah you had that the day
yeah after the tweet the day after the
tweet i was at the nearby like uh
train station yeah and i was about to go
into the [ __ ] train thing and then a
cop just like stopped me yeah oh sweet
and then he was like uh no
like i'll give this cop credit he was
nice about the whole thing but he was
like yeah uh so we're we're we've heard
about this uh case that's been going
around where people are uh picking up
credit cards of uh people and uh using
them without their permission so uh i
need you to like open your wallet and uh
i need to see some identification and i
need to see the names on your credit
cards
and at first i was like
what the [ __ ] is this like scam [ __ ]
that sounds like the most sus like
[ __ ] story so the wallet inspector
out there yeah no sorry so for the first
time ever i was like uh can i see your
identification please
because i wasn't too sure right yeah i
was like i need to make sure this guy's
a cop yes i was like can i see your
identification he looked at me like what
do you mean i'm i'm obviously dressed up
as a cop and i'm like no no i need to
say like your badge so he showed me his
badge i was like okay looks fine game
gave me the wallet he saw my japanese
name on my credit card yeah and he was
like oh nihonjin this guy
and i was like yes
immediately gives me back my wallet
and he was like oh dad's over there have
a good day sorry i thought you were
following me
yeah so basically yeah he saw my
japanese name
was like oh you [ __ ] you're japanese
whoops my bad here's your wallet back
have a good day it just went off and
then i and i stopped and just kind of
hid away to just see if he would stop
anyone else for like five minutes he
didn't stop anyone else he was just
walking around he was probably waiting
for the next foreigner so i was like
what if it'd been conor he'd been shot
yeah
he's just tased on the spot
you know it's also really annoying about
uh i guess just cops and security people
in japan is that you cannot tell the
difference by looking from a security
guard and a cop in japan they all dress
the same all the building like managers
and stuff also dressed like military
forces
really because like every mall i've been
to the security guard is like an 80 year
old dude really yeah dude and i'm like
what are you guarding you go into some
buildings and the security are dressed
like they're going to wall
and it's like where are you going i
don't know just everywhere i go they're
all dressed in like these military
outfits it's so weird maybe i like the
embassies and [ __ ] no
i've never been to an embassy in japan
security guards i've seen are like yeah
all decrepit yeah they're like they're
like 60 70 year old dudes with like hats
and they're like yeah where the hell do
you go yeah yeah
your dodgy massage
it's like the two places uh japanese
businessmen retire like like
i look at these like 70 year old like
security guards and i'm like okay let's
say hypothetically i like you know what
mother steal some [ __ ] what are you
gonna do well the security guards in
japan are there to call the police yeah
basically yeah they do yeah they're not
actually gonna hate you
i've never seen a secret just act like a
civilian right yeah i mean you know
you have that they call up the the group
of 15 cops
no but it was shocking because i've
never been stopped by like a company
that's the first time ever i've never
been stopped that was the first time
ever i've been stopped twice have you
ever [ __ ] hilarious i don't know you
do look a bit sort of dodgy though yeah
how do i the [ __ ] do i look dodgy i look
at you and i think that man needs to be
arrested
and
he's done some [ __ ] throw the key away
[Laughter]
in shinjuku presumably or something i
wanted um one of the old studio right
one of the old studios yeah police came
in
please please
stop this recording is there a mister in
here
the old studio
[Music]
a bunch of dudes walk past and this dude
just perked up when he saw me and just
like came over to me and just stopped me
and asked for my like id and all that
and i was like i was like nothing i just
gave him it i was like what'd you want i
could i could clearly see that he was a
police officer and i was like all right
well i guess i'll show it to you and i
was just bantering and stuff and he told
me about his favorite games and [ __ ] it
was weird it was fun i was telling him
that my train was leaving in two minutes
and he kind of he hurried up it's
interesting because that experience
sounds really
wrong right the whole sort of if he just
stops yeah nothing because you'll just
look like that and yeah
but then he was nice so it's kind of
like really trying to reconcile the nice
nice you know i don't understand why he
i wish that there was an explanation
even if he tried to explain to me i
wouldn't have understood anyway but it
didn't really seem like he tried to
explain why he was stopping me he just
stopped me and was like i did please i
mean he gave me an explanation and just
sounded like a scam oh dude just
straight up just like id card card you
just wanted my residence card and i was
like
one you assume ever i have uh which i do
but
you always need to carry a residence
card if you live in japan if you if you
get without it you can get fined like
100 000 yen yeah yeah like that like
when we have to send our um residence
card off to get renewed for our visa
which you know before happened to be
like every six months because we
couldn't get a visa beyond six months
that that like few weeks in between us
waiting to get oh my god yeah residence
card like that was just like yours
or something no because we have to send
off our passport as well jesus so the
only thing we had was a little bit of
paper said yeah yeah this is this
document that says that uh there's not
even like a document it's an email that
says oh they've sent it off and they're
getting it renewed and uh
i don't know how uh i don't know how
friendly the cops would be like just
open up this email
yeah every time i'm like uh i don't have
a zombie card like i was like ready to
like write the ticket he's like you
don't have a side
i don't really get too offended about it
it's a bit annoying but i i wish they
would just tell me why they're doing it
what what random random stop and search
yeah yeah random random yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
random
[Music]
yeah because like i've never seen a cop
do that with a japanese person like the
only time i've ever seen
japanese people are like when someone's
shouting or there's been a car accident
anytime i've ever seen it yeah like when
there's an actual i don't know if i'm
just being biased i could totally be
being like anecdotal evidence here being
completely biased i mean that's usually
what it is like when there's an actual
problem then the cops get involved but
when it's just a white guy walking down
the street apparently it's like oops i
do card time no it's never happened to
me and and the police i met have been
always very nice and friends yeah yeah
like i said like they're all nice
they're all nice yeah which is good i
told the guy i wanted to get my train in
two minutes and he kind of hurried up
yeah that's good i was like can't i need
to get that one and he was like oh two
more things
i got stopped for speeding once i was
going like four kilometers per hour over
the limit and it was one of those
situations where i just saw you see i
was going four kilometers per hour
speeding
they were stopping everyone they were
just stopping all the cars and because
everyone just in the countryside goes
over the limit a little bit yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah because the speed limit
is so low it is very low here and they
apologize for pulling me over there oh
my god we're so sorry we're so sorry we
know this is ridiculous
we're so sorry to inform you that you're
breaking the wall
they kind of knew that it was a bit
petty and uh sort of they could be doing
something points yeah i got a few points
i think for that for four years to pay
like some money oh my gosh
how mean i've been seven kilometers
why would they're playing fifteen twenty
i won't be getting a hundred percent i
mean a lot of people do go like 110 on
the like 70 or 80 miles yeah because the
highway is like 80. yeah so the mass
prior is like what 50 maximum 50 miles
per hour on the highways you're not
getting anywhere 50 miles an hour i get
it's a small country but you know people
got to go well you know to the uk it's
not a small country all right that's why
like you know you're not surprised when
you're seeing like there would be like
cars tons of them just getting like 110
yeah yeah yeah
all of them do it none of them follow
the rules
but apparently i was told i don't know
if this is true it's the person in front
who gets the blame if everyone's like
speeding behind the leader yeah whoever
because the leader is clearly the one
the insider
influenced them i don't know how true
that is i imagine if like 20 people are
speeding they can't stop every car yeah
you've got to set an example right
i've noticed that whenever like one car
goes in in the front yeah the other cars
just go back in yeah yeah they don't
want to be the one in the front yeah
that could be just make sense yeah i
don't know if it could be just
completely hysterical it makes sense but
i don't know realized i've been looking
at the wrong camera the entire time
looking at this one
you've been on this show
four times now chris oh my god